So we have just
two compositions,
both of the compositions
in the second half.
But rather than break
up the flow of those,
I want to just take
care of something now
which is very important to do.
Although the MIT wind
ensemble is participating
in the Great Clarinet Summit
along with the Festival Jazz
Ensemble, this is their
last official concert
of the academic year.
So I just want to acknowledge
the graduating seniors.
We have a few this year.
I'm happy that
there's only a few.
It gets-- it's always sad
when anybody graduates,
but when there's not--
when there's many, many,
it's even sadder, and
I'm more depressed.
So I'm only halfway
depressed tonight,
but still depressed nonetheless.
In any case, I want
to acknowledge,
and if I could just ask you to
stand up, that would be great.
In the flute section
graduating with degrees
in electrical engineering
and computer science,
Rachel Thornton.
[APPLAUSE]
In the oboe section, graduating
with a degree in biology,
Sue Lee-Anne [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
In the clarinet
section, graduating
with a degree in mechanical
engineering, Yasmine
[? Choppins. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
In the sax-- yes.
In the saxophone
section, Ronnie Ogden
with a degree in aeronautics
and astronautics, Ronnie?
[APPLAUSE]
And Rachel Morgan
also with a degree
in aeronautics and astronautics
[APPLAUSE]
All of these young
people have made
vast musical and non musical
contributions to the MIT Wind
Ensemble, and I thank them all
and will miss them all deeply.
I think Summer's coming
back, because they're
going to graduate school.
Can we all go to
graduate school here?
No, we're try to work on that.
At this time of the year, I also
present the Richard and Jody
Nordlof awards.
This award is presented to a
member or members of the MIT
Wind Ensemble in recognition
of distinguished service
and musical contribution
to the MIT Wind Ensemble.
I'm quite sad to report
that Richard Nordlof, MIT
class of 1955 and a long time
and ardent supporter of the MIT
Wind Ensemble passed
away in January.
We will hold a concert
in his honor next season.
This year there are
three recipients
of the Nordlof Award.
the first recipient has been the
principal flute and piccolo MIT
WE member for her
entire four years
and a frequent member of the
MIT Festival Jazz assemble.
She's also performed
with the MIT Symphony
Orchestra and
Chamber Music Society
and other things I
don't even know about.
Her dedication, consistency,
and intuitive musicality
is always bright in the MIT Wind
Ensemble overall experience,
Rachel Thornton.
[APPLAUSE]
Our next recipient has been a
dedicated member for four years
as well and has held the
soprano saxophone chair
for all of that time, as well
as playing fantastic alto
saxophone.
Wonderful musician and a
saxophone force of nature,
you've heard tonight in
both pieces, Ronnie Ogden.
[APPLAUSE]
Final recipient and also a
course sax ensemble member--
I don't know if you saw
the name of the group
but course six, of course, is,
kind of, ubiquitous major here,
and so the saxophone ensemble
calls himself course sax.
And another member is
someone who's anyway I
think of as a very kind of
most calming presence in MIT
student body, one of them.
She's a wonderful musician,
terrific saxophonist,
and is fiercely
consistent and dedicated
and has served as an MIT
officer for an entire four years
in the social chair role.
She has benignly
and very happily
forced us all to eat
together, skate together,
to attend concerts,
and play board games.
I think we played to some
interesting board games
for four-year-olds,
which is great.
So I'm all for that.
Congratulations
to Rachel Morgan.
[APPLAUSE]
Lastly, I just want to publicly
thank the entire MIT Wind
Ensemble.
While we're not done yet,
It's been a fantastic year,
and these people do many
amazing things in addition
to making music.
And I'm always amazed
when we get together
and I get to talk
with them one on one.
I end up interviewing them
as to what they're doing,
because it's so fascinating.
So I'm just very enamored of
what they do and who they are.
So thank you all very
much MIT Wind Ensemble.
And I do want to do one more
shout out to Ken [? Amos, ?]
the assistant conductor
of the MIT Wind
Ensemble, and a major force in
what this experience is about.
Thank you, Ken, who's up there.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, it's my great pleasure
to bring to the stage
to perform the Byron Concerto
for Clarinet and Wind
Ensemble, a great colleague
and dear friend to MIT WE.
But before I do, I
have to acknowledge
that due to an illness of
one of our clarinetists,
this great colleague I'm about
to introduce after playing
this concerto will also play
our last composition to fill in
for our ailing clarinetist,
Annette Wu, who we deeply miss
and who is watching, and we
hope for a speedy recovery.
Please welcome, Kenan
Sahin Distinguished
Professor of Music,
faculty director
of MIT Center for Art,
Science, and Technology,
and section head of music and
theater arts, Evan Ziporyn.
[ORCHESTRA MUSIC]
It's not in your program, but
there'll be a reception right
after the concert in
the lobby for everybody,
all the performers and
all audience members.
So please join us, and all
the students and composers
will be there.
Jamshied Sharifi is
certainly on the short list
of MIT'S most
artistically distinguished
and accomplished alumni as a
composer, arranger, producer.
He's a treasured
colleague and friend
and collaborated with the MIT
Wind Ensemble, the MIT Festival
Jazz Ensemble, and various
projects that sprout about here
on campus, big projects usually.
We love him very
much, and I'm honored
to invite him to
the stage to say
a few words about
his decomposition
awakening composed in
recognition of the Arab Spring.
Please welcome Jamshied Sharifi.
We haven't played really
great [INAUDIBLE]..
That was a hard piece.
Probably most of you know it
was Fred's idea for this piece.
And he was drive--
tell everybody the
story about it.
You were driving your
car listening to NPR--
Right.
That's right.
--about the Arab Spring.
And you thought what a great
[INAUDIBLE] for a piece.
And I think you emailed me
and told me within a day,
and said so how about this.
And Fred gets
really enthusiastic
about these things,
and his enthusiasm
is so overwhelmingly powerful
that no matter what you
actually think about
it, you say, yeah, sure.
Let's go.
So I [INAUDIBLE] started
looking into what
we knew about the Arab
Spring as it unfolded
and also trying to think
about wind ensemble,
because I've never
written for it before.
You find out really quickly
that you have this problem where
everybody has to breathe,
and so you can't just
have these really long
notes that go on forever.
But I slog through it and then
started having a lot of fun
writing it.
Like, it was really enjoyable.
It was musically interesting.
The challenge of writing for
wind, and mixing those colors
was really interesting.
And it was actually one of
the most joyful things I've
done musically, and it's turned
out to be a lot of fun to hear
and people say to play.
It's certainly been a great
pleasure for me to come back
here now for the third time and
hear different groups of young
people-- although I 0 there's--
Scott's still there-- different
groups of young people
engaging in the peace and
bringing their own shadings
and light to it.
But it really
comes back to Fred.
His enthusiasm,
his joy for music,
he's always searching
for new ideas that
could bring something
to the students
and to people around him.
So once again, I thank
him and the ensemble
for playing this so beautifully.
Thanks.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[ORCHESTRA MUSIC]